my name is fabulous ADA and they're
responsible for the development of the
wearable robot the robot is called body
extender and it is an extension of the
body of the user in the sense that the
system is able to track the complex
movement of the body and also to amplify
the force of the user the system has a
load capability of 50 kilograms for each
arm it can be used for performing
complex handling operation for example
in the manufacturing of complex product
or also for the rescue of survivors of a
network there are other examples in the
world of wearable robots but we can
claim that this one is the most complex
one in the sense that has a complete set
of degrees of freedom and for example it
has the possibility to grasp object the
heart is the ability also to rotate the
object not only to lift the object the
benefit of having a wearable robot is
that you can combine the intelligence
and the perception capability cognitive
capability of the human with the
strength of the machine in order to
bring the system to the market we need
the few millions of euros and the time
frame of three to four here